BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
Good afternoon everyone,
and welcome to the Making
Money on Google Play session.
My name is Brahim Elbouchikhi.
I'm a product manager on Google
Play working on payments.
BOB MEESE: And I'm Bob Meese.
I'm the head of games business
development for Google Play.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: So as Bob
and I got together and thought
about what would be some useful
things that we could share
with developers today,
things that could help you
make decisions as you run
your Android businesses.
And we landed on talking
about going global
on Google Play and
the aspects that
make Google Play a particularly
great platform for becoming
a global business.
So that we're going
to talk about today.
And we'll do so in two segments.
First, we'll look at data
and some product updates
from our end-- things that
will kind of produce by Google
that we can share
with you and give you
insights and best practices.
And then--
BOB MEESE: And then
for case studies,
we'll have two main focuses.
So first, we'll focus
on what developers
are doing to encourage users
of applications in players
of games to make a purchase
within the products,
and then second, how developers
are expanding to new markets.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: All
right, so let's get started.
Before we go too
far, I just want
to celebrate the announcement
from earlier today.
In case you missed
it, we've paid out
over $5 billion
dollars to developers
since we last met
here at I/O. This
is an absolutely exciting
milestone for us.
We could not have done it
without all of the work
that you all do.
After all, it is the
applications and content
you create that the
users actually purchase.
So incredibly exciting.
And we can't wait
for what we're going
to do next year and the updates
from next year and all that.
It's going to be
exciting, and this
is a huge milestone for us.
And we're super
excited about it.
So let's talk about the
next $5 billion dollars.
When we think of monetization,
there are two aspects to it.
There is the experience that
you build, the engagement that
happens within your application.
It is that which
ultimately triggers someone
to press the buy button.
It's that excitement
to unlock a new level.
It's that excitement to unlock
new features that ultimately
make a user press
the buy button.
And as anybody who knows
from a small business,
it is incredibly
hard to get someone
to actually give you their cash.
It's hard earned cash.
And so, within that, we think
our responsibility is that when
someone clicks on
that buy button
that we make sure that
we convert and turn
those clicks into purchases
for as many users as possible,
wherever they are.
And that's the
interesting aspect here,
is they're wherever they are.
We're on a global platform.
We have buying markets
in 134 countries.
And so the global
aspect of this is
that as we build our
payments platform,
we think about how can
we improve conversion
for your clicks, your buy
button clicks globally.
Now, let's talk about
the kind of thought
process for going global.
We always start with
what's familiar to us.
We start with a market that
we understand with a need
that we relate to as developers.
With a need that we relate to.
With a user experience
that we really love.
And then we expand from there.
They may consider going
to a similar market, one
where they speak
the same language.
And then from there, he may
go another distant market,
but one that has a similar need.
And all of a sudden, boom.
You're a global developer.
You have users and
buyers in 10, 20, 30, 40,
50 potential countries.
And so this is the exciting
thing about Google Play,
is that this is
achievable, and is actually
done on a daily basis by
developers like yourselves.
Now, I want to share with
you an interesting metric.
In the US, we
looked at developers
that are based out of the US.
And those that are earning
most of their income
internationally-- earn about
2.5.x those that aren't.
And this particular transition
has happened for corporations
in the past in the US, where
you're domestically based,
you earn most of their
income domestically.
And then one day, whether
consciously or not,
you actually start earning most
of your income internationally.
And as that happens, there
are things that change.
And again, whether consciously
or not, there are things
that change.
And it's important for you to
be conscious of those things.
Another interesting
metric I want
to share with you is
that over the past year,
globally, we had a 38%
increase in developers
that are doing just that--
earning most of their income
internationally.
This is really exciting to
us, because what it means
is that developers more and
more are using Google Play
and particularly using its
power as a global platform
to grow their businesses.
That's super exciting.
And we hope that this talk will
help even more developers go
in that direction.
Hopefully more than one.
So how do you go global
with Google Play?
The first part is really easy.
By publishing an application
on the developer console,
you're actually making it
available in 190 countries.
By making a product that
is buyable on Google Play,
it's already available to
users in over 130 markets.
And in 65 of those
markets, you can actually
tailor your pricing, which
we'll talk about later.
It's particularly important from
a user experience perspective.
So the first part, check.
You count all our
global merchants.
One thing we've learned about
payments over the past couple
years is that there's no silver
bullet-- except for cash,
but we can't take it
in digitally for now.
But otherwise, preferences
vary quite a bit.
So in the US, credit cards
are extremely popular.
In Japan, carrier billing is
the equivalent form of payment.
So interestingly, as you want
to build a global payments
platform, you actually
have to think very locally.
And these preferences
influence lots
of other things on the stream.
And so we'll talk
about that next.
So over the past year, we
spent a lot of time thinking
about these local
forms of payment.
How can we make sure-- again,
in each user for each country
as they come through and
click on that buy button
on your application--
how can we make
sure they do convert as
many of them as possible?
And one of the key
things we found
is that finding the familiar
form of payment, finding
the familiar experience, is
actually really important.
So we launched a Google Play
gift card in 13 markets.
We launched carrier billing
now in 25 markets total,
and we launched PayPal,
a longstanding user
and developer requests
in 13 countries.
We will continue to expand
these forms of payment
into more markets.
But at the same
time, we are going
to think more and more locally
about what forms of payment
work for users in each
of these countries.
So again, as we build a
global payments platform,
we have to think very locally.
Let's deep dive a bit into the
Germany launch of the Google
Play gift card.
Year over year, we've had a 70%
growth of buyers in Germany.
While this increasing buyer
engagement is really exciting,
what is really cool is what
this has done to our conversion
rates, our payments
conversion rate.
And we've had a 25%
improvement year
over year in our payments
conversion rates.
What this means is
that more of those
hard earned clicks that are
coming from your applications
are converting.
Partially because users are
finding forms of payment
are familiar to them.
Now at the end of the day,
what you care about is sales.
And over the past
year, we've more than
tripled our sales in Germany.
Of course, this is partially
due to the continued growth
of Android devices to
develop new forms of payment.
But also, the great content
and apps that you all
are creating for the market.
But when these aspects converge
in such a good and perfect way,
we see huge growth.
And so our work now is to
replicate this model elsewhere.
In Hong Kong, we launched direct
carrier billing and gift cards.
And over the past year,
we've seen an 80% improvement
in buyers-- increasing buyers.
In Russia, we launched
carrier billing,
and over the past year, we've
had 100% improvement in buyers.
Now let's talk about tablets.
Of course, tablets are an
important segment for us.
And some during the morning
discuss the growth in this
segment. .
But one really cool
thing we did today--
and as of today, actually--
is that we can extend carrier
billing to you use to tablets.
And this touches on another
important aspect of payments.
When you have a familiar
experience, when
you have a familiar
form of payment
that you use on a
regular basis, you
want to find that in every
device you're actually using.
And so extending carrier
billing to tablets
is particularly important from
a user experience perspective
as well.
And it will also include,
obviously increase,
revenue spent on tablets.
So we're super
excited about this.
It is available as of this
morning, my engineers tell me.
Woo hoo.
There you go.
Yes.
It's after lunch, it's cool.
So another aspect of,
obviously, any commerce business
is the content, is what
users are actually buying.
And we're always super excited
about launching new countries
where developers can sell
their apps-- where developments
can sell their apps from.
So, new developer countries.
And over the past year,
we went from about 30,
31 countries to
having 45 countries.
And what we see when we
launch a new payments
country for developers is
that a virtual cycle begins.
Developers start to
launch and iterate.
They improve their apps, they
target their content better,
and then buyers start to get
more engaged with that content.
And then the virtual
cycle begins,
and then we have an extension
of the Android ecosystem
the flourishes in that country.
And today I'm super
excited to announce
we're adding another 11
countries over the coming
weeks.
Our hope and mission is
that anybody anywhere that
can build an awesome
Android experience
can monetize and earn a living
in on it here on Google Play.
So we'll not dive
into things that you
can do to actually
take advantage
of Google Play as
a global platform.
Again, thinking initially
of the things that we do,
which is what we
just talked about.
And one of the things
that we believe,
best practices that
you can do to take
advantage of the
global platform.
First is localizing listings.
This is the best
practices that we
see most of our best
and top developers
that ear the most
on Google Play do.
It is pretty straightforward.
If you're addressing a user, you
need to speak their language.
You need to communicate with
them in a way they understand.
And Pocket, as featured
here, does a really good job
at localizing their
listings and the screenshots
to each of the
markets they target.
What we have observed
is is that broadly,
apps with localized listings
earn about six times those that
aren't.
So this is important.
And if you are consciously or
actively addressing a market,
you really need to localize
your listings and the experience
itself, by the way.
We do provide tools
on the developer
console to make this really
accessible to all developers.
You can take advantage of those.
Now, pricing.
Pricing is important,
and it's one
of those-- we have this really
easy to use auto convert
function, and a
lot of developers
take advantage of that.
And so, you hit
that button, it auto
converts into all
of our currencies.
And sometimes, you just
leave it like that.
What we were seeing
is actually that has
an impact on your sales.
We all know about
the $0.99 effect.
It's just that
price where somebody
thinks it's a trivial
purchase here in the US.
Or maybe it's a significant
purchase over $5,
or whatever that number is.
Well, that exists
in every country.
Every market has that
equivalent threshold.
And you need to consciously
target that price.
And so what we did is
we analyzed products
that are priced
at exactly 100 yen
and compared their
performance to those that
are priced slightly
over and slightly below.
Literally, two or three
yens, plus or minus.
And we see a 2x difference in
sales between those two groups.
There is no significant
change in price, obviously.
One more yen or 2 more
yen isn't actually
driving the conversion
improvement.
But when you user comes
through and you see 101 yen
as the price of this
product, it simply
is going to influence
their decision,
and it just comes
into that split moment
where you're making that
decision to buy or not.
It becomes an important
decision making factor.
So again, if you're actively
targeting the market,
you really need to consciously
price for that market.
Business models need to
be localized as well.
There are markets where
ads are the primary way
of earning sales and income.
But there are others where
in-app is the way to go.
There are others where
subscriptions-- especially
some apps categories
that Bob is going
to talk about next-- where
subscriptions is the best ways
to monetize your app.
And so again, as you
go to your application,
think of the various ways that
you can tailor that experience
to actually have a
different business model.
It is much more challenging,
I have to admit,
to build an application that
can support both subscriptions
and in-app.
But it is doable.
And if your category actually
is suitable for that,
you should take
advantage of that.
And adMark is announcing
there in-app purchase ads
which allow you to even
more easily acquire
users and buyers, which
is another tool for you
if you are an in-app
given business.
So localize your business model.
Now, let's deep dive
into subscriptions.
Since we launched
subscriptions, we've
been very excited
about the growth.
And today, we're
excited to announce
a number of new features
that will further
strengthen our platform.
First, we're
announcing that we'll
support in the coming few
weeks, weekly and seasonal
subscriptions.
Seasonal subscriptions,
for example,
will be extremely
good for sports
where they have a non-
regular recurring period.
Weekly, again, for
a faster occurrence,
for maybe shorter lifespan
type of applications.
Another exciting update
is about goodwill credits.
So it will allow you to actually
better retain the subscribers
by offering them a
goodwill credit in case
you had an outage,
or in case they're
just a really loyal subscriber
and you want to give them
a bit of a goodwill credit.
So it'll give you more
tools so you can better
engage and retain
your subscribers.
And you can build a
subscriptions driven business
on Google Play.
These features will be launching
over the coming few weeks,
so stay tuned on our blogs
for the announcements.
Going back to some of
the metric discussions.
Quality really, really
matters, as you'd expect.
And what we've
done here is looked
at apps that are rated
between three and four stars,
and those that are
rated between four
and five and the other brackets.
And you can see the
improvement in sales
between each of those brackets.
So as you invest in QA, bug
fixing, new device types,
new platform versions, replying
to reviews-- as you invest
in each of these,
there's obviously a cost
that you need to evaluate.
We would like you to have also
the upside, the possible upside
as you look at that
equation and analyze
what you would like to do next.
Now, we talked about tablets
and how awesome they are now
and how they'll soon have
carrier billing available
to them.
But one aspect of tablets as
well is that apps that are
designed for tablets earn about
10 times compared to those that
aren't.
And so as-- and
today is particularly
important for this discussion,
because we've announced so many
new form factors, so
many new platforms
you can reach, from
[INAUDIBLE] TV to auto.
And so if you are going to
be-- if your application is
an application that
is suitable for one
of these new platforms-- again,
designed for that platform,
explicitly designed
for it-- it will
make it easy to share APKs
across multiple platforms.
It is important
to actually design
an experience that
works for that.
And so, if a user comes
through on a tablet
and they're browsing
on a tablet,
they're simply not going
to have the same experience
and the same engagement
if that application is not
designed for that device.
So finally, to wrap up
this portion of talk,
to go global with Google Play,
you need to do a few things.
First, just think beyond
your familiar markets.
You're all entrepreneurs, and
as you start as an entrepreneur,
you're thinking of what's
most familiar to you.
But there is this
global multiplier
you can take advantage of, where
you can take the work you've
done for a specific market,
modify it according to what we
just discussed, and potentially
actually leverage it
to actually grow your business
and in a scalable way.
While you think
global, make sure you
think local-- you act
local, that's it actually--
you act local.
And so, localize your business
models, your languages,
your listings, your pricing.
Again, think local.
And then continue to focus on
quality and new form factors.
We've announced so
many of them today,
it's incredibly exciting.
But build and design for
those new form factors.
All right, I'm going
hand it off to Bob
who's going to walk us through a
number of the case studies now.
BOB MEESE: Thanks, Brahim.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB MEESE: It's so exciting.
This is the second year that
we've done this in a row,
and just like
seeing year to year
the progress is
amazingly exciting.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
my name is Bob Meese.
I'm the head of games business
development for Google Play,
and I'll review the case study
as part of the conversation.
And so first, before
we get started,
I just want to thank all the
developers that participated
and helped put this
content together.
As you can see
here from this map,
they're are all
across the world.
Some of you even traveled
here today for Google I/O.
And so, just really,
thank you for helping
provide your insights
into this presentation,
sharing them with me, letting
me share them with everybody
here today.
So thank you for that.
As I mentioned earlier,
I'll cover two main sections
in the case study part.
And so first, I'll talk
about what developers
are doing to encourage
users of applications
and players of games to make a
purchase within their products.
And so as Brahim
mentioned earlier,
we have this idea
of what happens
before someone
presses a buy button.
And that's largely the work
that all of you are doing.
And we'll talk
about some examples
of that-- and then what happens
after somebody presses that
buy button.
And Brahim shared all the
great work we're doing there.
And then the second part
will be some case studies
around how developers
are expanding
to new markets and geographies.
So let's get started
with the first part.
And so I'll cover six
different strategies
on this first topic of
encouraging purchase.
And you can see the developers
and the applications
that we'll cover there.
There are some commonalities
are similarities between them.
So you'll see that the
application developers
on the left-- all of them
are using subscriptions
to monetize the businesses.
And then on the right you'll
see the game developers,
and all of them are
using in-app purchases.
And so there's certainly
some commonalities
that we observed across
all these developers.
There's also some
differences too.
When you look at the strategies
that we'll talk about,
they are fairly different
across the developers.
So the first of all for
all talk about is Evernote.
So you look at, why
is this man smiling?
This is Phil Libin,
the CEO of Evernote,
the developer of a very
successful set of productivity
tools.
They recently
announced last month
that they now have more than
100 million users worldwide.
So they've been
quite successful.
They take a very
customer centric view
towards monetizing
their business.
They just want you to keep
using our applications.
They're very confident that
if you keep using Evernote,
eventually you'll
find a reason to pay.
Remember everything is
their motto, their mission.
It's very bold.
But if they deliver
on that, and if you
keep using their service, you'll
put more and more of your life
into Evernote and
they'll find a way
to help you pay for the service.
They really focus on the
perception of user value
over time.
And they see this big hockey
stick to the right here.
So here, what you
see is over time,
people become much more
likely to pay for Evernote.
In the first month after using
the service, only one half
of 1% of users actually
pay for the premium version
of Evernote.
Well, over time that
changes dramatically.
So active users of Evernote at
the one year point, 7% of them
have upgraded to premium.
At the two year point for
active users of Evernote,
11% of those people have
upgraded to premium.
And after five years, 25%
of active Evernote users
have upgraded to premium.
So for them, the goal is
just keeping people around.
And if you look at the
premium features for Evernote
you'll see why that happens.
Where they offer, for example,
offline access to your content.
They offer better search
across all the different file
types in your content.
And so there, you'll see that
as you put more of your life
into the service, you get
a lot more value out of.
And there's that aspect.
And so it's
essentially important
to think about
how you could have
some of these aspects in
some of your applications.
On the flip side, when I
was speaking with Evernote,
they give me a funny example.
They said, just
think of this idea
of perceived value over time.
And so I have a sandwich that's
either delicious or gross
depending on how old it is.
And so I think the perceived
value of the sandwich,
it may be five minutes.
Hits its max, and it cools
off, and five minutes
after it's made, it's great.
Evernote, they give
the five year mark,
five years after the
sandwich is made,
I want nothing to do with it.
It's going to kill
you if you ear it.
So it's really important to
think about just the user
perception of the value
in your applications
over time, looking for
services like Evernote
that tend to increase.
And sandwiches, obviously,
they go to zero very quickly.
It's something
where-- as we look
about the applications that do
this well, applications that
add personalization,
applications that they grow
their overall user
base over time--
those are the
applications that we
tend to become more
valuable over time.
And so look for opportunities
to add those types of features
to your apps.
The next company
I'll cover is Noom.
They were featured in the
keynote this morning, actually.
And they are a New York
City based developer
of fitness and weight
management applications.
If you eat a lot
of those sandwiches
we just showed,
you'll definitely
need Noom to help lose weight.
But what they really
focus on for monetization
is they recognize that
there's a seasonality
to the demand for
their business.
And so, around New Year's,
New Year's resolutions.
A lot of people are
interested in losing weight.
Around the period leading up
to summertime, a lot of people
are also interested
in losing weight.
And so, for a company
like Noom, they
can't be running
promotions all the time,
but they really try to
sequence those promotions
around the highest
demand periods of time
throughout the
course of the year
to capitalize on people who
are interested in upgrading
to Noom Pro.
And so here's an example of a
seasonally relevant promotion
that they ran just recently
for a summer sale-- 50% off
for Noom Pro.
And you'll see how they
executed that sale.
So they did an in-app promotion
that you'll see on the left.
At the same time, they
did an email promotion
that reached users
in different ways.
And then they followed
up four days later
with an in-app
reminder of that sale.
And then you'll see the results
on the slide of-- they're
able to spike their
revenue, which
is a really compelling thing.
And so they're able to deliver
three times revenue per day
by doing these promotions.
And the thing they really focus
on is you cannot run these
promotions all the time.
But find the times during
the course of the year
where the demand is
highest your services,
and run promotions then.
Noom also really, really
has some cool uses
of data in terms of
helping to convince
people to upgrade to premium.
And so here, there's an
in-app message that says,
we've looked at data
from millions of Noomers.
And what we've found
is that the people that
have upgraded to Pro, they're
losing twice as much weight
as the people that
are just using
the free version
of the application.
And so here, this is a
really compelling message
to deliver to people
to get them to upgrade.
And when you look
at the features
within the
application-- so, Noom
Pro groups-- it's
a way for people
who have similar
goals to get together.
Noom Pro also unlocks additional
content, provides personalized
recommendations, and a
priority customer support line.
And so these are
some of the features
that Noom is using
to upgrade people
to the Pro version
of the application.
Next we'll talk
about Smar Education.
They are a developer
based in Tokyo
that makes apps for
children's education.
This is [? Akia Than ?] who
is the CEO of Smart Education.
So, over the past year,
they've made a big pivot
to their business to
really focus on free trials
and subscriptions
in their business.
And so this is an
example of a promotion
they ran within the most
successful application,
which happens to be based on
a popular Japanese TV show.
And they did a bunch
of testing in terms
of different types of
promotions they could run.
And they found that
offering a free trial
was very effective in terms
of getting people to sign up.
What they found was a one
week duration of the trial
was the optimal
duration for them
in terms of getting
people to start the trial,
and then getting people to
convert after that period.
And effectively,
what they're doing
is breaking the purchase
decision into two.
And so they were able to share
some very impressive statistics
that they have.
And so here on your left,
you'll see the number
of the percentage of
people who installed
the application and those
who started that free trial.
And that was about 8%.
But I think, very
impressively, of those people
that did the trial,
60% percent of them
actually started the
subscription, which
is a very impressive number.
And when you put
that together, you
get 5% of the
installs of this app
fr Smart Education converting
to a premium subscription.
And I think people who have
a recognition of how hard it
is to convert people
into payers recognize
how impressive a result this is.
Smart Education is not
just a one hit wonder.
And so when you look
at their presence
on that top charts for the
education category in Japan,
they're doing quite well.
And so here, half of
these applications
are Smart Education,
so five of ten.
So it's been great for them.
Now, moving into the games
part of the conversation.
This is Mediocre.
There are actually two guys.
So this is Henrich and
Dennis, based in Sweden.
And it's just really,
really easy like these guys.
They developed a great
game at few months
ago that's called Smash
Hit that's done quite well.
And so when you talk
about them, they're
actually not the
most-- they don't
run a ton of analytics
in their game.
They're a little bit
different than most developers
in that way.
But what they really focus on
is building a trusted brand.
And what they--
when I was talking
to them, one of things t
that really came out is just
they want to develop games
where people just-- players want
to tell other people about them.
And that's obviously
great free marketing,
but it's earned as well too.
These guys are not spending
anything on marketing.
But they really focused
on creating a product
that people love that they
want to tell others about.
And so it's really,
in some ways,
a simplistic
modernization strategy.
But they really focus on
the quality of the product
and delivering that
for their players.
And of course, you can't
forget the purchase
funnel as well too.
Historically, Mediocre
had done something
where they would
have where they would
have a paid version of the game.
And they would have a
free version of the game,
and it would be very separate.
And you would upgrade but
it was a little bit awkward
to move within the two.
So here, they have in this
game for the first time, what
I believe is a much more
compelling and elegant purchase
experience.
And so for me, when I'm playing
the game on your left here,
you'll see I play
for about 15 minutes.
I play through to that point
and I die, unfortunately.
And I have a big
promo that says, hey,
would you like to continue
through the progress
that you've made.
And it's a pretty
compelling statement
at that point of the rest
of the time of the game.
If I say, yeah, sure.
I click anywhere in that circle,
it immediately says, hey,
would you like to get
the premium version,
because that's
what's required to be
able to save the progress
that you've just made.
And Mediocre is
quite modest in terms
of only asking for
$2 from any user.
And so they actually convert
quite well in this dynamic.
But it's a really great focus
of great content and really
elegant purchase
experience that's
made this game quite successful.
Also don't be afraid to show
your personality as well, too.
So you go through, you
make that purchase.
They actually pop an
achievement that says, hey,
you've just received the
developer love badge.
So, thank you very much paying.
You're supporting
two dudes in Sweden.
And so that they make it
feel a lot more personal.
It's something-- they don't
have to this obviously--
but that's what
encourages people.
That's part of what
encourages people
to tell their friends
about the game.
And if you just at
the results here.
So the blue line at the top
is the top three ranking
for the game in the US,
and the red line below it
is the top grossing line
for the game in the US.
And you can see here that
the free rank, the installs
were just amazingly successful.
So in March, for
several weeks, the game
was number one, topping even
games like Candy Crush that
have been mainstays on
the top of the free charts
for a long time.
I mentioned that Mediocre has
a more modest modernization
strategy, just looking
for $2 from each user.
And so they're never
going to be making
millions of dollars a day.
But this outcome at 57 is great
for any number of developers,
let alone a developer
that's two people.
And so this is
what I would argue
is a very successful outcome
for these developers.
Next up is my.com, the
developer of jungle heat,
and they' are based in Russia.
And who you see here is the
games team for Jungle Heat.
And so their approach
was a bit more structured
in terms of encouraging
first time payer conversion.
And so they did this trial
here where they specifically
focused at the top of
their funnel on their new
and their non paying users.
And there, what they
decided was there
was a specific point in
the overall experience
of consuming the game
where they would focus
on trying to convert
people into being payers.
And so, in this case, it was
after someone had completed
the tutorial, and then
after they had then
won three player versus player
battles within the game.
At that moment-- that's
the second come on.
The third was, they looked
at what the offer would be.
And the offer within this game
was a 2x value versus normal.
And so for the same price that
somebody would normally pay,
that person would
receive 2x the diamonds.
And you can see that
called out in the lower
part of the screen.
And then within that,
you have this offer--
you need to bound
that somehow by time
to create a sense of urgency.
And so in this case, there
is a timer that counts down
to say-- they were generous
and they ran this promotion
for one day.
And so you would have one
day to claim this promotion
for the discount to convert you
into a payer within the game.
And so the result
here was very good.
And so during the week
they ran this promotion,
they were converting
two times more
than they converted
in the previous week
when they weren't
running a promotion.
And so there, they're seeing
great results from doing these.
And again, various developers
stagger these promotions.
You can't do them
all the time, and you
need to find for
every developer what's
the right cadence for you
to run these promotions.
And finally, in this section of
the talk, I'll adress Playtika.
This is them showing off their
beautiful office in Tel Aviv.
And for them, they
are quite impressive.
I'm hearing more
and more developers
talking about
player segmentation.
And looking at
Playtika is really
the leader in this regard
among game developers.
And so, some of history
what they've done.
Over the past several
years, at the top
here, they used to not segment.
And so they would deliver
the same gameplay experience
and the same user communication
to all their players.
Next down, they
offered what they
considered basic segmentation.
And so some of what you've
heard earlier, segmenting out
the people who have paid within
the games versus the people who
have not, and then offering
different communications
to those two groups.
And the third, in
terms of advanced,
you're starting to get much
more real time information.
And so as you have more
nuanced information
about people and
about their game play,
then you can start to be
more structured in terms
of creating more and more
segments in a more automated
way.
And then finally, as they
think about potential for what
they would call
hyper segmentation,
there they're adding
more machine learning
and automated approaches.
So removing some
of the humans who
are doing some of this advanced
segmentation and letting it
become more
algorithmic over time.
And so, tangibly
what does this mean,
they've talked with us a bit
about the business intelligence
solution that they have, and
the evolution of that over time.
And so in the beginning when
you're not doing segmentation,
they were really just focusing
on accurately collecting events
from players.
And so for example, if the
game goes offline or crashes
for whatever reason,
making sure that you
have a very accurate
and reliable data
store within the application.
Next is you move into
segmentation that'
more of the basic format.
So there, if you
remember they're
just segmenting
out the people who
have paid within the games
versus the people who have not.
When you have these
very discreet buckets.
For example, some
of the things they
could do to encourage
purchases are they
could have their email
marketing team send an email
out to non payers over the
course of the week giving them
special promotions.
As you move through
the advanced category,
you're getting
much more real time
data within the application,
within your analytic systems.
And so rather than having to
do weekend long promotions
towards a very broad group of
people like all of your non
payers, you can start to do
much more fine grain promotions
to people that are
much more fine grain.
And so there we could
do, for example,
is send personal
notifications to people
based on their game play.
And so how often
they're playing,
how many sessions per day, for
how long the sessions last.
And you can have a very
customized communication
to those users based
on the game play.
And then finally, for
hyper segmentation,
there's key here as
I mentioned earlier,
is adding additional
machine learning
in automated approaches
to what humans
are doing in the advanced state.
And so here, the results are
again just very compelling
where-- just based on
this segmentation alone
Playtika noticed that
they were getting
a 30% uplift in new
payer conversion
from what I just mentioned.
More broadly, too, they're
seeing a revenue uplift
of 50% overall for the
segmentation activities
that they're doing overall.
And so they're seeing both an
impact on new payer conversion
as well as their
overall revenue, which
is quite impressive
at this point.
All right, next we'll cover
expanding to new markets.
And so here, we'll cover a
couple of developers already
mentioned briefly, and then a
couple that are more specific.
And just in terms of
breaking this down,
there's certain developers
that have applications
like Smash Hit, like Evernote.
As I mentioned, just
broadly applicable.
And Google Play is
very powerful in terms
of allowing those developers to
reach just a global audience,
in many cases, without
much customization.
And then at the
bottom you'll see,
there's a lot of developers--
we get a lot of interest
in terms of, how
do I go to Japan?
How do I come to the US?
How do I reach
other Asian markets?
And so we have a
couple of examples
of developers that
have done just that.
And so there's a
difference between those
that are looking for the
broad swath of geographies,
and then some specific
target geographies.
And so if you look
at Smash Hits,
I showed that the US graph
of the results earlier.
But their success was hardly
constrained to just the US.
And so here, there's
a bunch of countries.
They were number one in
23 different countries
during that time.
And if you look at just a
couple rungs down the latter,
so if you look at the
top five-- that not 23,
but it's an additional
11 countries.
But there within the
top five top free.
And so for a developer
like Smash Hit,
they invested a
relatively modest amount
in terms of changing the game.
It's a relatively simple game.
And so it's the
power of, if you can
create a compelling yet simple
experience on Google Play,
you can reach this
vast audience and have
just a great amount of success.
Then Evernote is similar
too where Evernote says,
they have the same
service worldwide.
They believe that they're
addressing a universal need.
And so they don't feel a need to
radically change that service.
As I mentioned earlier,
Evernote announced last month
that they have now
over 100 million users.
And they're based
here in California.
But if you look at how
those users are distributed,
their biggest areas
is actually APEC.
And their second
biggest area is Europe.
And so it's not-- the US is the
third largest region for them.
And so it's been really
powerful for them
to be able to reach such a
broad demographic and broad base
of countries with that service.
And when you look at
it, Evernote-- it's
very language intensive.
And so while they believe
that it's OK for the service
to be consistent
across geographies,
they obviously
need localization.
And so here, they're
based in the US
and so obviously they
started with English.
And then Brahim had
mentioned earlier too
about what is familiar with us.
And so the other
countries that they chose
were Russia and Japan.
And Russian-- because
Phil who I showed earlier
is actually born in Russia.
And a number of early
Evernote employees
were actually Russian.
And so just starting
with what is familiar
and authentic-- this is
clearly an example of that.
And Japan was just--
for whatever reason,
they started to get a
bunch of users in Japan.
So that moment, you decide,
OK, do we establish a presence
here, are we going to
really lean into this,
or is this something where
we need to pull back.
And so in their case, they
established an office,
they established
customer support.
They really focused on investing
in the quality of translations
that they were doing
for the Japanese market
and were very successful.
And so on the basis
of those first three,
they've grown to 14
and up 34 languages
that Evernote is supporting,
and it's growing all the time.
Next, I'd like to talk
about the developers
Space Ape and their
game Samurai Seige,
which although it launched
recently in Japan,
it's been successful so far.
And there's just
a lot of interest
in terms of Western
developers who
say, how can I be
successful in Japan?
So we'll talk a little
about what they've done.
And so this is the 50 or
so people in the company
and their avatars
on the website.
So you can see that,
definitely a fun group
of people who don't take
themselves too seriously.
And so in terms of how
they prepared for Japan,
there were just a
couple of key steps.
And so localization
is really important.
And so doing a lot
of the localization
of the game by hand
is really important.
And so, as Brahim
mentioned, localization
is something that
really important.
You can't necessarily just trust
the autofill for these things.
You need to do
something that feels
authentic in the
local geography.
And then on that point too,
they invested in a local team
as well with country
manager, customer support,
and all of that.
Local PR too.
Just reaching the publications
that the local gaming
audience pays attention to is
really important for Space Ape,
and they found
success with that.
Game play.
So they did a soft launch.
They believed that they didn't
need to change the game,
they wanted to test that to
make sure that was the case.
So they did need to
provide a super custom
version of the game for Japan.
And finally, in terms
of what was not done.
So as I was just
mentioning, they
didn't fork a version of the
game to be Japan specific.
They believe that the core
global version of the game
would be appropriate for
the Japanese audience.
And they also didn't
work with a publisher.
So by investing
so many resources
into the Japanese audience,
they felt confident
that they could be
successful on their own.
And so in terms of the results.
So on the left, the game
developers in the room
will see these results.
And they'll know
that it's early,
but they're quite impressive.
Particularly the
per user metrics.
In terms of the lessons
learned, Space Age
really focuses on live events.
And the Japanese market
really rewards live events.
A lot of the best
Japanese developers
run great live events.
And so that was simply
something that was successful.
The localization that they
invested in was very helpful.
And as I mentioned, by
reaching local PR outlets,
they were able to reach
some really strong players
in that way.
Next is Com2us in
their expansion,
they're a Korea based
developer in their expansion
of their game Ace Fishing
to Southeast Asia.
This is the local game
team for Ace Fishing.
And so you can see, this
is the revenue pie chart
for Ace Fishing.
Very impressively, more
than half of their revenue
is coming from Southeast Asia.
And the second largest piece
of the pie is actually the US.
It's not until you get
to the third largest
piece of the pie, which is
their home market in Korea.
So obviously they're having a
lot of success internationally.
When you look at
what they're doing,
they're investing
very significantly
in locally
appropriate marketing.
And so here, for Southeast Asia,
they're doing print magazines,
they're doing online magazines.
They're doing web tunes
for community engagement.
They're doing outreach to power
bloggers to get game reviews,
and they're doing a whole
slew of media and PR
that you see on the
right in addition
to working with us to make
sure that we're supporting them
with our local teams.
Then finally in here
we'll talk about Gumi.
And so here, Gumi
is a company as you
can see-- these guys
are also smiling,
they're doing amazingly well.
They're really a model
for global expansion.
And here's a big
reason why, I think.
It's not something they're
just bolting onto the business.
But when you look at them,
they're based in Tokyo,
but here's all the
various offices.
They have about half
of their whole company
outside of the headquarters.
And they give them a
lot of autonomy as well.
In many cases, they're
calling the heads
of these local offices
the CEOs of those offices.
And so Gumi, unlike
the other companies
takes a very local approach
to distributing their content
in various geographies.
And so here, I mentioned
around customization.
So their game Brave Frontier has
been their most successful game
from Japan coming to the US.
And some of the things that
they're doing are obviously,
translation is kind
of table stakes.
But they have made the tutorials
very different as well too.
And so RPG games in
Japan are quite common.
You don't really need as long
of a tutorial in that geography.
First in the US, there's a
lot of game players here,
but they want to reach
a broader audience,
and so they made
a longer tutorial
to help educate a broader
demographic who may not
be familiar with this type of
the game about the value that
provides.
And they've been quite
successful with that.
And then even a
more extreme sense,
they've changed some of
the game play mechanics.
So some Asian countries that are
accustomed to PCI online gaming
culture where session
lengths are quite long,
Gumi actually removed the
energy mechanic from its game
for those geographies.
So they're willing to invest
in extreme customization
with its games when
it's appropriate
for the local audience.
And see here as I
mentioned, Brave Frontier
has been the most successful
Japanese game in the US.
Here's the results
from this here.
And they've reached
a peak top grossing
rank of number six, which
is extremely impressive
and have held onto
that quite well
for the course of the year.
So that almost wraps
up our presentation.
But just in summary, how
we think about making money
on Google Play, we're really
working in partnership
with all of you.
And that's why the two
of us do this every year.
But it's really all the
work the developers are
doing to encourage the
users of applications
and the players of games to
make that purchase, and then
the responsibility that
we have to keep investing
in our platform to be launching
more and better features
every single year.
And then the global
piece as well too.
So just delivering great
advice to all of you
about how you can build
your business globally.
And so activating all of the
local markets that are there,
helping you
localize, helping you
learn from others that are
succeeding these other markets
to help you be
successful globally.
So before we go, we want to
call out a couple of sessions
in particular.
And so our friends
Kho and Yoshi are
going to be presenting tomorrow
at 9:00, Goin Global on Google
Play.
It won't have as of
a monetization theme,
but it'll be a lot
of similat topics.
Highly, highly
recommend that talk.
And then please do the second
one, the Google Play power
session.
So Ellier Powers who did
such a great job this morning
presenting the keynote will
be up next on this stage,
so please stick around for that.
So thank you very much
for your time today.
[APPLAUSE]